Then he mentioned a number of hadiths
that indicate the
asceticism of the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, and his family, including those of Al-Bukhari, may
God have mercy on him.
This is like the hadith of Aisha, who
said, "The family of Muhammad, peace and blessings be upon him, did not eat their fill of wheat
food for three consecutive nights since they arrived in Medina
until they passed away."
This, as we have said, demonstrates the virtue of asceticism and contentment with little, and that
this is the character of the
prophets.
And this is just as we have said; this is
the virtue of
the
character and
all the prophets. And
among that is her saying, may God be pleased with her, "The family of Muhammad, peace and blessings be upon him, did not eat
two meals in one day
except one of them was
dates."
Aisha, may God be pleased with her, may
God bless her and grant her peace.
Likewise, what was narrated from Aisha, may God be pleased with her, was that the
bed of the Messenger of God, peace and blessings be upon him, was made of leather and
stuffed with leather fibers. His bed was made of
leather, may
God be pleased with him. All of this indicates his asceticism
in this world.
Aisha, may God be pleased with her, may God bless her and grant her peace,
mentioned the hadith of Qatadah, who said, "We used to visit Anas ibn
Malik..."  And his baker was standing and
said, "Eat!" I don't know that the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, ever saw a thin loaf of bread
until he passed away, nor did he ever see a roasted sheep with his own eyes. A roasted sheep
is a sheep roasted with its skin on. May
God have mercy on him. Imam al-Bukhari,
Qatadah, may God be pleased with him,
Anas, Malik, and Anas, may God be pleased with him. And similar to this is
the hadith of Aisha: "A month would pass and we would not light a
fire, but only dates and water, unless
we were brought some meat." Meaning a little meat, may
God be pleased with her. [
Music]
[Music] And
he mentioned the hadith of Aisha, that she said to Urwah, my
nephew: "We would
see the new moon three times in two
months, and no
fire would be lit in the houses of the Messenger of God, peace and blessings be upon him."
Meaning that the new moon would come, the month would begin, then the new moon would
end the month, then the new moon would end this
month, all three new moons, and no fire would be lit in the houses of the
Messenger of God. All the women had
fires.
This is also evidence of the Prophet's, peace and blessings be upon him, asceticism
in this world. If he had desired
this world, yes, the
hadith of Aisha, may God be pleased with her, Urwah, may God be pleased with her, may
God be pleased with her.
[Music]
[Music] May
God be pleased with him.
[Music] So
I said, "And what do you live on?" meaning, "What do you eat?"
She said, "The two black things." The two black things refer to
dates and water. Urwah
Aisha, may God be pleased with her, said, "The one with the black things."
However, the Messenger of God, peace and blessings be upon him, had
neighbors
from the Ansar who had livestock. They would give the Messenger of God, peace and
blessings be upon him, milk from their homes. We gave him, peace and blessings be upon him, a drink. A livestock is when a man gives a sheep or a
camel so that he may benefit from its milk. So these
neighbors had livestock and they would give the Messenger of God, peace and blessings be upon him, and his wives some of
this milk,
sharing this milk with them for the
love of God Almighty.
[Music]
[Music] And
this also shows, in addition to the Prophet's, peace and blessings be upon him, asceticism,
the importance of caring for neighbors and the
Muslim's kindness to his neighbor.
God, peace and blessings be upon him.
[Music]
He mentioned the hadith of Abu Hurairah that the Messenger of God, peace and blessings be upon him, used to
say, "O God,
provide the family of Muhammad with sustenance."
Imam Bukhari, may God have mercy on him,
Abu Hurairah, may God be pleased with him, God, peace and blessings be upon him,
Muhammad, peace and blessings be upon him, and sustenance,
meaning sufficiency,
meaning the need that is enough for the body,
not to the point of satiety, and in that is
safety
from afflictions.  Wealth,
as well as safety from the afflictions of poverty,
is between them. He lives with sufficiency, neither rich nor poor,
destitute.
This is his strength. Sheikh Aksbin Hamdallah
[music]
The Imam, may
God have mercy on him,
mentioned in it the hadith of Masruq, who
said: I asked Aisha, may God be pleased with her, which deed
was most beloved to the Prophet, may God bless him and grant him peace.
Aisha, may God be pleased with her,
said: The constant. He said: I said: What time did he get up
at night? She said: He would get up when he heard the call to prayer.
In this chapter and hadith, there is
encouragement to persevere in good deeds, even if they are small. A little that is consistent is
better than much that is intermittent.
[Music]
Because a little that is consistent
prevents the servant from becoming bored and thus
ceasing to worship. Be consistent in your actions, and this includes praying at
night, reciting the Quran, and giving charity. The
important thing is to continue
and worship your Lord until certainty comes to
you.
[Music] A small amount of consistent
good deeds prevents
[Music] from coming because it is not exhausting, so therefore it does not cut you from doing the deed because it is small and it is consistent, such as for. And Allah also encourages hastening to good deeds and taking the initiative to perform righteous actions. [Music]
And his saying, "When the rooster crows," the rooster is the one who crows a lot
when he reaches the end of the last third of the night, the time of Suhoor. The
Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, would seek forgiveness
and pray.
Yes,
Sheikh, may Allah preserve him,
love Allah, the Most High, and
this emphasizes for the brothers,
especially those who live here with long working hours, that a
day must pass without them allocating time for
Allah in reciting the Quran. In the realm of knowledge,
do not let the world be your greatest concern, lest you be lost.  Your hours and
your whole day are spent working, working, working. If you come
home, you sleep. You must dedicate time to worship
God Almighty.
[Music]
Do not pass, do not pass, you
accept
God Almighty.
God, the Exalted, the Majestic. And it was
mentioned in a hadith of Aisha,
which is similar in meaning.
She said, "The most beloved deed to the Messenger of God, peace and blessings be upon him, was that which its doer
persisted in."
Imam Bukhari, may God have mercy on him, may God be pleased with
her.
God, peace and blessings be upon him. And
he mentioned the hadith of Abu Hurairah, may God be pleased with him, who said, "The
Messenger of God, peace and blessings be upon him, said, 'None
of you will be saved by his deeds,'" may God be
pleased with him.
[Music] He said, "Not even
you, O Messenger of God?" He said, "Not even
me, unless God envelops me in His mercy." [Music]
God Almighty. Be
moderate and strive for balance, and be quick and easy, and a little bit of darkness, and moderation, moderation, and you will reach
[Music]
God.
In this hadith is a
statement that the servant will not be saved except by the mercy of God Almighty. And
God Almighty. And
the evidence from this hadith and
what it contains of the command to be moderate and strive for balance and be quick and
easy.  And his spirit, and all of this
indicates continuity in work and not
interrupting it,
neither a little that is interrupted nor a lot that is destructive. He should be
moderate in matters,
according to a sheikh. He said, "He does not do good deeds. They are small, and however,
they are cut off."
And his saying here
that none of you will enter Paradise by his deeds,
and the Almighty’s saying, "
That is Paradise which you have inherited because of what you used to do."
In the hadith, he negated entering Paradise by deeds, and in
the second, he affirmed that entering Paradise is by deeds.
How can this be reconciled,
Sheikh, love of God Almighty, may God bless him and grant him peace?
[Music]
God, the Exalted, and the following
answer is that the
hadith, or the “ba” in the hadith, “by his deeds,”
when we say, “None of you will enter Paradise because of what you used to do,” the
intended meaning here is the “ba” of
correspondence or compensation, meaning
that Paradise is
not equal to your deeds, no matter what they are. No matter what you do, even
if you worship God night and day,
God’s favor is greater.
This is the meaning of the hadith.
As for the “ba” in the verse, “
Enter Paradise because of what you used to do,” or “That is Paradise which you have inherited because of what you used to
do,” this “
ba” is the “ba” of causation,
meaning that one of the reasons for entering Paradise
is deeds.
So, the summary of the answer is that no
matter what you do, Paradise is greater than your deeds.  Your work
and you will enter it by the mercy of God,
but
work is a reason for entering it.
Work is a reason for entering it. Yes,
Sheikh, may God Almighty preserve you. Sheikh
[music]
not parad, not parad to act, you perform
these actions
[music]
because of what you were doing, a
reason for
parad.
Est
paraduse
for parad. Glory be to Him, the
Most High. And
also in this hadith is a statement of not relying on
work, rather it was the way of the
predecessors,
as they were described in the Qur'an: "And
those who give what they give while their hearts are full of fear," meaning
they do the work and fear that it will not be accepted from them.
God Almighty
[music]
God Almighty, the Most High. God Almighty, the Most High [music]
God, the Most High. And
it came with asceticism on the authority of
Abdullah bin Amr bin Al-Aas, that he used to say:
This religion is firm, so
delve into it gently,
meaning perform the acts of worship gently and do not be excessive or
harsh on yourselves
so that you do not stop working.
Sheikh, may God Almighty preserve you.
Asceticism,
Abdullah bin Al-Aas, Abdullah bin Amr bin Al-Aas,
may God be pleased with them both
[music]
This religion is firm, so delve into it gently  And do not
make yourselves hateful to yourselves the worship of God, the Exalted and
Majestic. He
said, “For the one who is overexerted neither reaches his destination nor preserves
his mount.” The one who is overexerted means the one whose mount is tired or whose animal is injured.
This is the one who puts so much pressure on his animal while traveling that it becomes tired, so he neither reaches his destination nor preserves his mount. He
neither reaches his destination nor preserves his mount. He added, “
To the extent that, for example, the extremism is that of a man who is extreme towards his riding animal, so therefore he puts
so much pressure and force upon
his riding animal when he is traveling upon it, so
therefore his riding animal
leaves him, so he is not traversing in any way.” [
Music]
So, the meaning of “be moderate” is that it means correctness and justice.
As for “be moderate,” this is a prohibition against being strict and an order to be moderate
in matters. And “go early and go late.” Going early,
as we mentioned earlier, is the beginning of the
day, and going late is the end of the day.
[Music]
God’s portion.
Likewise, “night travel,” which is traveling at night.
He said, “Something of the night travel,” meaning he does it during the day, and “
something of the night travel,”
meaning he
also mentioned something similar in the hadith of Aisha
that the Messenger of God, may God bless him and grant him peace, said  Do good deeds and strive for excellence,
and know that whether
or not one of you will enter Paradise through his deeds, the most
beloved deeds to God are those that are consistent, even if the heart... This is a
hadith of Aisha, may God be pleased with her.
God, may God bless him
and grant him
peace,
mentioned after it a hadith of Aisha that she said: The Prophet, may
God bless him and grant him peace, was asked: Which deeds are most beloved to
God?  He said, “
Even though it is few, take upon yourselves only those deeds which
you are able to perform
and within your capability.”
And the saying here, “Take upon yourselves only those deeds which you are able to perform and within your capability,” means strive in performing acts of
worship, such as prayer and
other acts of worship,
to the best of your ability.
[Music]
These
acts of worship,
for example, increase in your prayer, however, do
so in a manner where you are not overburdened.
This indicates the
command to be diligent in worship,
but with the condition that it does not lead to hardship that results in boredom and weariness,
to the point that one abandons worship. My
Sheikh, Adel, may God Almighty bless him and grant him peace.
[Music]
With
any hardship, any difficulty.
[Music] And
likewise, Alqamah said, “I asked the Mother of the Believers, Aisha, ‘
O Mother of the Believers,
how was the practice of the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him? Did he dedicate any particular
days?’
Imam Bukhari, may God have mercy on him,
said, ‘No, his practice was consistent.’
And the meaning of ‘consistent’ is that he was constant in it.
This is like light, continuous rain, which is called ‘deen’ in the language.”  May
God be pleased with her.
[Music]
Alive
This shows that the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him,
had a consistent worship throughout the day. There was
no specific day that he designated for increased
worship without a reason. Rather, his
worship was continuous and constant.
Then she said, "And who among you can do what the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, could do?" May
God be pleased with her.
Meaning, the Prophet's worship
differed from that of the Companions. He could increase
both in quantity and quality,
but his worship was as Aisha described it. May God be pleased with her. And
he also mentioned another narration from Aisha: The Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, said, "Be
moderate
and strive for perfection, and rejoice, for no
one will enter Paradise by his deeds alone." He said, "Not even
you, O Messenger of God?" He said, "Not even me, unless
God envelops me with His forgiveness and mercy."
Imam Bukhari, may God have mercy on him.
Aisha, may God be pleased with her, when she said the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him.  He
said, "Do good deeds properly, sincerely and
moderately, and receive good deeds, because
good deeds will not make him enter into the paradigm. They ask you, 'Even me,
until He
protects me and gives me.'" And
Mujahid's interpretation of "saddad" was mentioned
when interpreting his saying, "a sound word." He said, "Saddad means
truthfulness." So the meaning of "and they acted soundly" is that they acted truthfully in their deeds. This is from
Imam Bukhari, may God have mercy on him. It is
Mujahid's interpretation of "
saddad" as "saddad" [
music]
meaning "
saddad"
[music]. And
he mentioned the hadith of Anas
at the end of this chapter.
He said, "I heard," or "The
Messenger of God, may God bless him and grant him peace, said," or
Anas said, "The Messenger of God, may God bless him and grant him peace, led
us in prayer one day."
In one narration, it is the noon prayer. Yes,
Imam Bukhari, may God have mercy on him, hadith of
Anas bin Malik, may God be pleased with him, may
God bless him and grant him peace,
noon
[music].
Yes, then he ascended the pulpit and pointed with his hand towards the qibla of
the mosque.
He said, "I have been shown now, since I led you in prayer,
Paradise and Hell
represented
in the direction of this wall," meaning
depicted.
This is evidence of the existence of Paradise and Hell, as we said, Glory be to Him, the Most High. The
believing servant must worship God, the Almighty, and
combine the three pillars of worship:
love, fear, and  And please,
Sheikh Khalid Al-Dhafeeri, may
God Almighty preserve him.
[Music]
God, the Exalted, the Most High, the
believer,
if he worships God Almighty with hope only, then
this is the state of the people of Irja’ and his worship. And
worshiping God with hope
alone
leads
to feeling secure from God’s plan and not fearing Him.
God Almighty, the Exalted, the Most High ...  The correct interpretation is that
the verse was revealed to the Jews
when they said, "We believe in what was revealed to us," and disbelieved in what
was revealed to Muhammad. So, for
the people of faith, a
sign of happiness is to
obey Allah and
fear that He will not accept your deeds. And a
sign of misery is to
disobey Allah and
hope to be saved. Aisha
explained the Prophet's (peace and blessings be upon him) interpretation of the verse, "And
those who give what they give, their hearts are fearful."
He said, "Those are the ones who
pray, give charity, and fear that
Allah will not inform about them."
Then he mentioned the hadith of Abu Hurairah that the Prophet (peace and blessings be upon him)
said, "Allah created mercy on the day He
created it, 100 mercies."
Imam Bukhari (may Allah have mercy on him) narrated this from
Abu Hurairah (may Allah be pleased with him).
Allah (peace and blessings be upon him)
kept 99 mercies with Him and sent them all out as
mercy.
This is evidence of the vastness of Allah's mercy, the
Exalted.
If the disbeliever knew all the mercy that God has, he would not
despair of Paradise.
God Almighty says, and
this is the hope mentioned in this hadith. And
if the believer knew all the punishment that God has, he would not feel secure from
Hellfire. This is the fear of
God Almighty.
[Music] He
said: Chapter on patience in abstaining from what God Almighty has forbidden.
His saying
[Music]
Almighty God says, “Indeed, the patient will be given their reward without
measure.” And Umar said, “We found the best of our lives in patience.”
God Almighty says, “Patience is of
three kinds:
patience in obedience, patience
in abstaining from disobedience to God,
and patience in accepting God’s decrees.”
Therefore, patience is among the greatest deeds in reward.
[Music] Rather, they will be given
their reward without measure. This is an indication of the
greatness and vastness of the reward.
[Music]
Rather, Umar mentioned that one of the greatest reasons for living in
comfort and tranquility is that
God Almighty grants him patience.
Then he mentioned the hadith of Abu Saeed al-Khudri
that some people from the Ansar asked the Messenger of God, may God bless him and grant him peace, and none of them
asked him except that
he gave to him until they had nothing left.
Bukhari, may God have mercy on him,
Abu Saeed, may
God bless him and grant him peace,
said to them when everything was gone  He spent with his hand or
his hands
whatever good I had, I would not withhold it from you.
And when everything was finished and all that was in it was spent, he said, "If anything will be made to be patient,
God
Almighty will make him patient, and
whoever seeks to be self-sufficient, God will make him self-sufficient." And you will
not be given a better or more abundant gift than patience.
In this hadith is an encouragement to be self-sufficient and to refrain from
asking people through
patience and reliance on God. This hadith is a beautiful expression of God Almighty's generosity, may God bless him and grant him peace. It
also shows
that the reward is of the same kind as the deed, and whenever a servant does
something, God Almighty gives him something of the same kind as his deed. He
also said, "Whoever seeks to be patient," meaning to
treat himself and accustom himself to patience, God Almighty will make him self-sufficient and patient, may God bless him and grant him peace. And then, "
Whoever seeks to be self-sufficient," meaning by God, and turns away from